it's official trailer should no longer
be referred to as a preview of a movie
they should be referred to as a
standalone short film has absolutely
nothing to say about the film you're
about to see that Los Angeles has been
very very anticipated a lot of people
have really really been into the trailer
of this film
they love the musical score that's
accompanying why the trailer you're
thinking man this could be like a really
awesome non-stop kind of action movie
just really cool just a big flat-out fun
kind of popcorn entertainment movie and
you know when I first saw the trailer I
was thinking the same thing I was like
you know that looks interesting I love
alien invasion movies it could be a fun
summer popcorn movie and so I was kind
of pumped for it trailers are very
deceiving aaron eckhart plays Staff
Sergeant Nantz I believe is his name and
the reason I can't remember is because
you know what characters really isn't
that important in this film the film
opens in a very cliched way he's just
about to retire as usual he's going to
do one last mission he's gonna help
these guys in a train ever he's going to
teach him how to fight and everything
you know we've seen it a million times I
just saw a film called Heartbreak Ridge
starring Clint Eastwood and directed by
Clint Eastwood I think it's one of those
best movies I suggest you check it out
it has a very similar cliched plot
however it is handled very well back to
better Los Angeles so on his retirement
day we get the news that there's these
meteors that are coming down except
they're not meteors they're aliens and
they're invading the earth and they're
landing in order to get these creepy
news report things Aaron Decker has to
take these Marines who don't really
trust him because in the past he lost a
lot of people in a war and so he has
kind of like a bad history none of the
action this from
remarkable because there are so much of
it and it's so incomprehensible and so
mindless you have no idea what's going
on bullets are flying by lasers are
flying by you can't tell who fired who
where they're shooting what they're
shooting at how that person is now dead
how that lying creature is now dead you
don't know what happened you just saw a
whole bunch of flashes of lights a whole
bunch of bullets whizzing by some sound
effects and now some people are down
some creeks they're down and you don't
know who shot who this film is
essentially a giant first-person shooter
game now if I was a 13 year old kid who
didn't know any better I probably think
this is the next coolest thing since
whatever the last big videogame shooter
that came out was but I'm not and I saw
right through this movie there is some
serious issues here when it comes to
this director he has no style of his own
it's just the same old zoom in quick
zoom out zoom in quick look at that
shake shake shake shake shake
zoom and quick edit quick edit quick
quick quick we could do it go do a quick
should sue min quickly we won't have to
add too much effects to the background
so we can just kind of have him shooting
in and you know it'll look cool and
everything and good sound effects and
intense music and they'll like it
they'll like it they'll go and see it to
tell their friends and they'll be great
no it's not great basically this is
essentially a Michael Bay film without a
director who knows how to direct action
because let's face it Michael Bay is
good with special effects
some of them from transformers 2 were a
little bit hard to tell what was going
on but nonetheless he's pretty good with
making action scenes even if they're
completely mindless this director has no
idea what he's doing there's a line of
people here they fire there's a line of
creatures there they fire zoom in on
them that'll look neat character
development they could kill all those
soldiers and you know the only reason it
would be sad is because it's the idea of
a human dying and that's supposed to be
sad the script of this film is just so
bad it's one of those scripts that
explains everything to you and if
something strange or different happens
on-screen where the characters has to
explain it in some lengthy explanation
so will make sense to be apparently dumb
viewers who can't understand a film just
by watching it I hate when filmmakers do
that listen I am just a guy I love
filmmaking I love to do these movie
reviews but I'm telling you professional
people out there in Hollywood that a
movie is better when you don't explain
it to us if you are a smart director you
will help us to
stand the story through your direction
through your storytelling ability you
don't have to have someone stand in
front of the screen and explain it to us
it makes us feel like idiots battle Los
Angeles does have some good stuff I'm
sorry that was a big rant I just wanted
to get out of the way this film is not a
horrible film at all Aaron Eckhart gives
the standout performance of the film he
is a very good actor and I really like
him he's the only character I cared
about he's the only one who had some
flesh and blood to him he's character
took chances his character had ingenuity
he came up with things in the heat of
battle he has literally the best scene
in the film and the only great scene in
this film and it has nothing to do with
action is a great scene in this film
with good dialogue and good tension the
film isn't boring it's very fast-paced
in regards to the fact that pretty much
from the start of the movie to the end
it's just these Marines that are in this
situation and you're with them it's
essentially like watching your friend
play a video game but you're not
involved with the game you're just kind
of watching them play it basically this
is like a cross between War of the
Worlds and Independence Day except the
director has none of the talent that
Steven Spielberg has and the characters
have none of the likeability of Will
Smith and Jeff Goldblum and Independence
Day you've got a mindless alien invasion
movie I'm going to have to give battle
Los Angeles two out of four stars and a
lot of people like won't you do it ten
come on seriously that that comes out to
five out of ten do the math it works the
same way the stupid movie pick me
out I know I gave Red Riding Hood the
same rating but it is better than that
film the reason I'm giving this a lower
rating is because there was so much
potential here for a fun summer action
popcorn kind of film useless direction
piece of crap writing and literally one
good character and one good performance
in this film at a Marinette cart he's
the only thing in this film that is of
any saving grace I don't recommend by
the Los Angeles you'll probably check
out anyway because it's a hyped up movie
but
No and on his retirement day we get this
news these meteors are coming down then
we learn hey you know these aren't
meteors these are alienated and on his
retirement day we get this news hades
and on his retirement day we get these
news and on his retirement day we get
the news of these my gosh what is
happening i chewed gum that's what it is
my mouth dishonorable